depuis que depuis qu'elle a gagné la
star préférée dans l'astarac appelé sur
mon portable ont un sens c'était une
autre nolwenn et tu m'appeler parfait le
matin super temps maison à le domaine
s'appelle sa mère n'a alors pas du tout
et je vais vous dire ce n'est pas du
tout un dos nolwenn minon saint-amé tête
je travaillais quelqu'un qui s'appelait
n'est pas exactement sa mère à l'avoir
jamais je t'ai dit je t'ai jamais envoyé
de sms du genre nolwenn mais j'étais
consciente que tu m'appelles mais
c'était pas pour me parler mais plein de
fois ai-je assurément vous avez eu des
saignements des domaines le roi elle te
regardes quoi il est plein de gens qui
ont vu avoir le numéro de nolwenn
comment vous l'aviez vous avez parce
qu'on s'était rencontré un jour oui
c'est ça qu'on est chez sa mère mais je
fais partie de la famille moi je suis le
traiteur chesnais le roi il m'appelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rêverait alesi ou fréquentant le loool
il faut le prochain sidaction on peut le
faire avec a capella allez-y j'entends
le loup le renard et la belette où il a
chanté malade ne fait pas de faire un
petit truc qu'on accable que je suis fan
de votre voix n'importe quelle chanson
vraiment tout ce qui est franchement
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas contre
martine moi franchement pour les
téléspectateurs on aime tellement la
voix de nolwenn elle est incroyable
avant d'accueillir camille combal qui va
nous foute un derrick dans la gueule moi
j'adore mais je vais fermer des yeux je
vais bien trimark plus l'audio bank al
adha
la nada
trimark blu ray aux banques
rooney d'avis gages il revenait d'un
virage iguer rooney d'un viager grandes
villes bécasse est à nada la liberté
qu'est topic est rien
[Musique]
bon si tu vois là
mamoudou dème
c'est pas simple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
également
alors on va faire un blind test on va
voir qui va gagner entre enora et
nolwenn attention c'est l'essai l'ailier
vince seibert alors vous allez jouer il
ya le mentionne alors plus que ça
puisque chaque fonds il en faut en vie
d'ilan fou il en faut beaucoup qu'il en
faut plus
ben hmida lui parce qu'il vaut mieux pas
le mettre dans le nid de gilles verdez
aller alors attention dès que vous avez
la bonne réponse vous presser comme ça
l'était pas il faudra alors attention
premier titre
c'est parti
[Musique]